une puissance militaire n'est effective
que dans l'action militaire donc vous
avez des grandes puissances sur le
papier et puis on voit ensuite quand le
combat arrive si ça fonctionne ou pas
c'est notamment le cas de la chine si
jamais il devait y avoir une guerre on
verrait on verra comment la chine se
débrouille aujourd'hui vous avez dans le
monde que trois pays qui ont une
expérience du feu continue depuis 1991
c'est la russie les etats-unis et la
france l'angleterre il ya peu renoncé et
l'allemagne également
donc ce sont des experts du feu à ces
différentes mais qui est réel qui veut
dire également qu'on peut tester les
matériels et surtout qu'on transmet
l'héritage de la guerre qu'on a des
générations on voit le général lecointe
qui prend sa retraite il a commencé dans
les guerres de yougoslavie on a une
nouvelle génération pianic ça c'est
extrêmement important dans la manière de
faire la guerre d'avoir cette
transmission est cette continuité des
générations du feu et ça fait d'ailleurs
un point commun entre moscou et
washington et paris et les russes
s'étaient rappeler ont cette capacité
d'avoir un très bon ratio entre moyens
employés et gains obtenus qui
effectivement l inverse et états unis
les français sont un comédien
mais ce qui manque également notamment à
la france et aux etats-unis cette une
définition claire de ce qu'on appelle
l'état final recherché quand les russes
interviennent en syrie c'est clair ils
veulent maintenir bachar al assad et ils
veulent essayer de détecter des
puissances occidentales et en
tchétchénie s'agissait de pacifier la
région ce qu'ils ont réussi ou y compris
dans la douleur nous au sahel on n'a pas
véritablement d'objectifs clairement
définis
pareil quand on intervient en libye on
voit bien qu'on change un petit peu au
fur et à mesure et que finalement ça
finit par le renversement de kadhafi ce
qui n'était pas prévu à l'origine
donc il nous manque une une claire
définition d'une stratégie diplomatique
relations internationales et
géopolitique est donc un appareil
militaire qui se coordonnent d'un point
de vue tactique à la stratégie que l'on
définit et pour l'instant on en reste
dans les mots donc la défense de la
démocratie
l'arsenal et démocratie où le monde
libre
mais sans dire exactement ce que l'on
entend et ce que l'on veut atteindre
comme objectif ni quels moyens y compris
militaires mais pas que on est capable
dit m
[Musique]